Ich weiß nichts über WikiLeaks, es ist nicht
mein Ding, und ich weiß, dass es etwas
mit Julian Massage zu tun hat. Ich
habe gesehen, was mit Assange passiert ist,
und das wird eine Entscheidung sein, die
ich mir vor allem vom Generalstaatsanwalt vorstellen würde, der
so hervorragende Arbeit leistet
er wird eine Entscheidung treffen ich weiß
nichts wirklich über sie es ist nicht mein
es ist nicht mein Geschäft im Leben ich habe nicht
wirklich eine Meinung ich weiß, dass der
Generalstaatsanwalt daran beteiligt sein wird und
er wird eine Entscheidung treffen okay es ist nicht
Zufall, dass diese
Angriffe genau im selben Moment und alle zusammen
zur selben Zeit stattfinden, in der WikiLeaks
Dokumente veröffentlicht, die die massive
internationale Korruption der Clinton-
Maschinerie aufdecken, einschließlich 2.000 weiterer E-Mails erst
heute Morgen,
und alles, was Sie tun müssen, ist einen Blick auf
WikiLeaks zu werfen und  Sehen Sie sich nur an, was sie
über Bernie Sanders gesagt haben, und sehen Sie, was
Deborah Wasserman Schultz im Sinn hatte,
weil Bernie Sanders zwischen den
Superdelegierten und Deborah Wasserman
Schultz nie da war  r hatte eine Chance und ich war
so überrascht, ihn
heute in einer neu veröffentlichten
E-Mail über WikiLeaks wieder mit dem Teufel unterschreiben zu sehen, dass wir erfuhren,
dass Katz ik Informationen
über die Untersuchung der Clinton-
Kampagne fütterte, und das ganz richtig, und das
sagte Kazik  Zitat, es wird eine Weile
dauern, bis das Außenministerium die
E-Mails veröffentlicht, je mehr E-Mails WikiLeaks
veröffentlicht, desto mehr Linien zwischen dem Büro der
Clinton Foundation, dem Außenminister,
und den
persönlichen Finanzen von Clinton, sie alle werden verwischt,
sogar Chelsea Clinton und die WikiLeaks-
E-Mails wurden ausgewählt. Express-Zitat  ernsthafte
Besorgnis über Interessenkonflikte bei
der Clinton-Stiftung des
Außenministeriums haben wir erst heute erfahren, dass Hillary
Clinton hochgradig geheime
Informationen über ihre gemachten, sagten Sie,
gerade erst vor kurzem herausgekommenen Personen gesendet hat, die
daher uneingeschränkten Zugang zu diesen
Informationen hatten, was den Staatsangehörigen vollständig gefährdet
Sicherheit der Vereinigten Staaten kam
dies gerade heraus, WikiLeaks zu anderen
Ländern einer der Hauptgründe, warum ich
mich engagiert habe